las hamburguesas son la especialidad del
restaurante caminito cabaré en el barrio
13 de parís y en tiempos de pandemia uno
de los pocos platos de su exigua carta
desde el 30 de octubre están cerrados y
sólo pueden vender para llevar
pese a ello el espíritu no decae ni
tampoco la afluencia fiel del público
es una forma de ayudar y además nosotros
tenemos que comer de todas maneras
elegimos los lugares que más nos gusten
hoy vine a tomar un examen presencial a
mis alumnos y aprovechamos para venir a
almorzar al mediodía como solíamos
hacerlo
veníamos seguido a este restaurante y es
una buena ocasión para apoyarlos en este
periodo como se practica
los restaurantes en francia estuvieron
cerrados tres meses durante el primer
confinamiento y volvieron a cerrar el 30
de octubre pasado sin perspectivas de
pronta apertura los pocos que han
sobrevivido como el cabaré caminito de
aurelian lo hacen gracias a las ayudas
públicas
hace un año que sólo luchamos por
sobrevivir pasamos el día calculando
cómo hacer para que nuestra empresa no
se hunda la materia oscura la venta para
llevar es cool pero no es viable
económicamente no somos un fast food
no vamos a distribuir hasta altas horas
de la noche además nuestros precios son
más altos que los de la comida rápida
para redondear sus fines de mes aurelian
y su equipo tienen un puesto miércoles y
domingo en este mercado de barrio es una
iniciativa de la municipalidad de parís
y cada día experimentan diferentes
propuestas de minutos jamón y no la de
este campeonato
no es fácil volverse experto en
panqueques como tampoco atravesar esta
crisis pero una buena dosis de humor
hace las cosas más fáciles